Trascrizione: Marco Ramazzotti
La pressione sociale esiste,
ha un peso fisico.
Ce ne rendiamo conto meglio
quando non è esercitata su di noi,
ma su qualcuno che amiamo.
Quando ho messo al mondo
una piccola donna,
mi sono resa conto
di cosa sopportano le donne,
fin dalla loro nascita.
Viviamo in un mondo in cui ci sono
molti modi giusti per essere un uomo,
e nessun modo giusto
per essere una donna.
E viviamo in questo mondo
da molto, moltissimo tempo.
Fare o non fare figli,
separa le donne.
Tutte le persone
possono fare un sacco di cose,
ma solo le donne possono
fare altre persone.
A un certo punto della tua vita, se sei
donna, o sei madre o non lo sei.
Che questa cosa ti capiti
o che sia una scelta,
in qualsiasi caso sarai sbagliata.
Se io dico "Madre", nella testa di ognuno
di voi si apre un grande catalogo,
di virtù e di azioni,
spesso inconciliabili
che spettano di diritto
e di dovere a una madre.
Ce l'ho anch'io naturalmente!
Anche se aver a che fare coi figli
ogni giorno
è un buon allenamento per mettere
in discussione i propri preconcetti.
Io ho sempre voluto fare
un sacco di cose nella vita,
diventare madre non è mai stato
nei miei piani...
e poi è successo a me.
Questo evento magico, meraviglioso
si è abbattuto sulla mia esistenza
come un'ascia,
d'improvviso ero a un bivio:
come avrei potuto continuare ad essere
la persona che desideravo diventare
e allo stesso tempo essere
una buona madre.
Intorno a me tutti sorridevano,
erano felici, entusiasti... loro.
Io non mi sono mai sentita così sola.
La maternità mi ha insegnato
un sacco di cose.
Ad esempio che ho molta più pazienza
di quello che pensavo,
che non dormire per settimane
ti rimette in forma splendida,
una dieta che tutti i genitori conoscono,
che lo schifo può manifestarsi
in forme assolutamente
inimmaginabili e sconosciute,
e tutte da un esserino delizioso e tenero,
ma soprattutto che il futuro
è una dimensione reale
che possiamo abitare solo se
restiamo ancorati con il nostro passato.
Privare la vita
di una delle due dimensioni,
priva l'altra di senso.
Mia figlia è nata una domenica notte
di fine estate.
Qualche giorno dopo ero a casa,
credo che fosse notte,
ma quando ti prendi cura di un neonato,
e soprattutto nei primi giorni,
il tempo è una dimensione relativa.
E infatti, Einstein ha inventato
la teoria dello spazio-tempo
quando è diventato padre.
Lo ricordo come se fosse adesso:
un'infermiera emozionata,
dall'altra parte di un telefono
che aveva appena squillato,
mi chiedeva se mia figlia stesse bene.
Le analisi neonatali avevano rivelato
che Viola soffre
di una sindrome genetica rara.
Tutti i miei buoni propositi di essere
una buona madre
erano falliti da principio!
Ero una pessima madre,
con un cattivo sangue,
avevo fatto una figlia malata.
Non mi sono mai sentita così sbagliata.
Dal giorno dopo,
mia figlia è entrata in terapia.
Ma quella notte,
tra il 5 e il 6 settembre 2009,
io non ho chiuso occhio.
In quel momento così difficile,
in cui tutto è andato in frantumi,
io ero a pezzi,
non sapevo cosa sarebbe successo
il giorno dopo,
nessuna persona viva
poteva capirmi o aiutarmi.
In quella notte ho incontrato la donna
che mi ha cambiato la vita.
Una ragazza morta.
L'avete vista anche voi,
[foto]
nel cinema, nei videoclip,
sulle copertine dei dischi,
nei cataloghi d'arte,
nei cataloghi delle mostre di fotografia.
L'hanno soprannominata
"il suicidio più bello del mondo",
o più semplicemente
"fallen body, il cadavere precipitato".
Per decenni l'arte, il cinema,
la fotografia
hanno reso omaggio
alla bellezza del suo ritratto funebre.
Ma di lei, di chi fosse, della
sua storia, nessuno si è mai interessato.
Nella sua solitudine mi sono rispecchiata.
Il suo nome era Evelyn McHale,
aveva 23 anni
quando la mattina del primo maggio 1947
si è lanciata dalla terrazza più alta
dell'Empire State Building.
Dietro di lei un vuoto di domande
e un brevissimo biglietto d'addio.
"Non voglio che nessuno mi veda,
nemmeno la mia famiglia.
Vi supplico fatemi cremare,
distruggete il mio corpo.
Niente funerali, niente cerimonia.
Il mio fidanzato mi ha chiesto
di sposarlo a giugno,
ma io non sarei mai una brava moglie
per nessuno.
Dite a mio padre che evidentemente
ho fin troppe cose in comune
con mia madre."
Due cose mi hanno legato subito a lei.
Quell'espressione "buona moglie",
che esattamente come "buona madre",
avevano per me un significato chiaro,
senza che nessuna
di noi due si fosse spiegata.
A distanza di settant'anni,
quell'etichetta è rimasta intatta,
ha superato il millennio.
Ed evidentemente, a lei,
faceva lo stesso schifo
che faceva a me.
E poi,
il riferimento a qualcosa
di generico e di sbagliato,
che la legava a sua madre: delle "cose".
Una trasmissione di errore
che mi chiamava direttamente in causa.
Quella notte ho adottato
il cadavere di Evelyn McHale,
e lei ha adottato me!
Che avevo bisogno di un'amica.
Che mi aiutasse a ridare
senso alla mia vita.
Ho dedicato i successivi otto anni
a capire chi fosse quella ragazza,
qual era la sua storia,
il significato delle sue parole,
che cosa l'avesse portata lì.
Ho poi scritto un romanzo
su questa storia.
E come sempre succede,
la storia di una donna conteneva
la storia di molte donne.
Un intero secolo di donne.
Evelyn McHale è nata nel 1923
a Berkeley, in California.
Era la sesta di sette figli.
Sua madre si chiamava Helen
[foto]
ed è stata per moltissimo tempo
una buona moglie e una brava madre.
E poi ha smesso.
Suo padre si chiamava Vincent,
era un uomo in carriera
e la sua famiglia era parte
di questa carriera.
Lavorava per la Federal Bank
in un momento in cui,
dopo il grande crack
e poi con il New Deal,
il grande sistema bancario
americano cresceva.
Avere una famiglia numerosa
aveva un valore
anche in termini di reputazione.
Così, Helen faceva i figli,
sette,
badava alla casa,
e traslocava a ogni
nuova promozione del marito.
E poi, a un certo punto,
non ce l'ha fatta più.
Nel 1930 la famiglia arriva a Washington,
Evelyn ha sette anni
e sua madre comincia a dare i segni
di una profonda depressione.
E se non fosse stata depressione?
Se fosse stata solo una donna
insoddisfatta di una vita
al servizio del marito,
stufa di essere
il migliore dei suoi biglietti da visita.
Se non fosse stata depressione,
se fosse stata solo una persona infelice,
una donna infelice,
ma non avesse nessuno
che desse valore alla sua infelicità.
Quando leggiamo i libri di storia
troviamo delle date molto precise.
1912, la marcia per il voto a New York.
1916, l'apertura della prima clinica
per la pianificazione delle nascite,
a Brooklyn.
1917:
la contestazione del presidente Wilson
e l'arresto di 218 donne.
Nello stesso anno
l'arruolamento in massa
delle donne in marina.
1921:
la fondazione della "A.B.L.C."
la Lega Americana
per il Controllo delle Nascite
che afferma, per la prima volta,
che i figli devono nascere
anche dal desiderio consapevole
della madre
e che devono essere concepiti
nell'amore e non nella violenza.
Questa è la storia.
Ma cosa succedeva nelle cucine delle donne
come la signora Helen MacHale-Smith...
Ancora oggi, dopo tanti anni,
[foto]
ignoro il motivo per cui Helen
abbia lasciato i suoi figli
se ne sia andata da casa,
o sia stata mandata via.
Se anche avesse una ragione,
un motivo, un malessere profondo,
nessuno si è curato di farcelo sapere.
Suo marito Vincent ottiene
la custodia di tutti i figli,
anche quelle minorenni.
Li porta con sè a Tuckahoe, a New York.
Qui Evelyn finisce di frequentare
le scuole superiori
e poi si arruola nell'esercito,
nelle "WACs": Women's Army Corps,
che sono quasi sempre assenti
dai libri di storia.
Eppure le donne sono state indispensabili
per la vittoria americana
nel secondo conflitto mondiale.
Sono state arruolate dopo tutti gli altri,
persino dopo i neri.
Eppure sono diventate le migliori.
Anche nell'Army Air Force,
[foto]
l'aeronautica militare,
erano 40.000 le donne arruolate.
Nel '45 sono in missione all'estero,
con oltre 200 ruoli professionali diversi,
un esercito nell'esercito.
Ma l'esercito più potente d'America
era quello delle massaie, rimaste a casa.
Il presidente Hoover
ricorda che, durante la guerra,
le munizioni più preziose
erano le bistecche
e i tagli pregiati di carne,
da mandare al fronte per mantenere
i soldati in forza e in salute.
Per questo nel '41 viene creato
un comitato per le abitudini alimentari
che ha lo scopo di istruire,
a loro insaputa, le massaie
a cucinare per i figli e i mariti
piatti con ingredienti definiti esotici,
per non dire schifosi...
lingua, trippa, interiora, cuore, fegato,
tutto quello che rimane
dopo i tagli pregiati di carne.
Nel '45, quando la guerra finisce,
Evelyn è a New York.
Abita con il fratello e la cognata
e lavora come impiegata
nel distretto finanziario di Manhattan.
A una festa, una sera, conosce
l'uomo che le chiederà di sposarla.
Ha un anno in più di lei,
si chiama Barry Rhodes,
è un veterano come lei della guerra,
un ex-pilota dell'aeronautica,
che frequenta la facoltà di ingegneria
al Lafayette College,
a Easton in Pennsylvania.
Barry era uno che, prima della guerra,
non poteva studiare.
Ma, da veterano,
l'università gliela paga lo Stato.
Quando finisce la guerra
e fino al settembre del '46
viene attuata una grande operazione,
si chiama "Tappeto magico",
col compito di reintegrare
nella vita civile
un esercito di 16 milioni di militari,
per il 97 per cento uomini.
Per reinserire questa massa
di uomini adulti nella vita civile,
il presidente Roosevelt
firma un provvedimento
che è passato alla storia
come "G.I. Bill".
Una grande copertura,
un grande investimento
di 500 milioni di dollari,
che offre tra l'altro
delle borse di studio
per frequentare l'università.
Il "G.I. Bill" è un grande successo.
Quattro anni dopo la fine
della guerra, nel '49,
il 70% dei laureati è un ex-militare.
L'investimento pubblico
nella qualificazione degli ex-militari
è fondamentale per il rilancio economico
degli Stati Uniti nel dopoguerra.
E sulla carta,
il "G.I. Bill" è il primo provvedimento
che sostiene il capitale umano,
senza discriminazione
di razza o di sesso.
Questa è la storia.
Ma per quelli come Evelyn e come Barry
[foto]
le cose andarono un po' diversamente.
Anche le veterane invasero
i College, naturalmente.
Ma per loro
la formazione universitaria,
la qualificazione
non ebbe un effetto positivo,
al contrario.
Alla vigilia della guerra lavorava
una donna su due,
nel 1950 sono una su tre.
Parte delle coperture finanziarie
vennero trovate tagliando servizi che
avevano sostenuto il lavoro femminile
in tempo di guerra,
come gli asili pubblici.
Sondaggi condotti molti anni dopo
rivelarono che, alle donne
che chiesero di mantenere
il lavoro con cui avevano sfamato
la famiglia in tempo di guerra,
vennero imposti tagli
di orario e di stipendio
fino all'ottanta per cento.
Mano a mano che uscivano dai College,
alle donne vennero levate
le posizioni di comando,
vennero negate le promozioni.
Non potevano accedere
alle cattedre prestigiose,
vennero loro negati i riconoscimenti.
Immagino che questo non vi sorprenda.
Il soffitto di cristallo,
esattamente come le pressioni sociali,
è una costruzione socio-economica
che pesa sulle spalle di tutti noi,
da troppo tempo.
Nel 1945
Evelyn McHale è una giovane donna
che vive e lavora a New York
e fa progetti per il suo futuro.
Nel 1947
è una giovane donna che si uccide,
scrivendo nel suo biglietto d'addio:
"...non sarò mai
la brava moglie di nessuno..."
Possibile?
Che nel grande sogno americano
del dopoguerra
non ci fossero alternative per lei?
Ho iniziato questo talk
[foto]
raccontandovi di come sono diventata
amica di una ragazza fantasma.
Rimettere insieme i frammenti
della sua vita
mi ha aiutato a capire
che il mondo in cui io,
da donna, da professionista, da mamma
mi sento a disagio,
è il risultato di una lunga
somma di tradimenti
ai danni di tutte le donne.
La guerra di genere è l'unica
che non è mai finita nel Novecento.
La crescita delle democrazie
non ha incluso le donne come cittadini,
si è limitata a considerarle strumenti.
a dividerle tra utili e inutili.
Ancora oggi,
a ogni piccola conquista nella vita
pubblica come in quella privata,
sottilmente, più o meno esplicitamente,
dobbiamo rispondere sempre
alla stessa domanda:
"A che cosa servono le donne?"
Bene,
è il momento di rispondere.
Le donne non sono funzioni.
La buona moglie, la brava madre,
la donna dietro un grande uomo,
quella che cura, quella che accudisce,
le donne non sono funzioni, sono persone.
Finché questa non sarà
una verità per tutti,
finché le nostre democrazie saranno sorde
alla rivendicazione delle donne,
finché umilieranno la loro rabbia,
finché il confronto
non avverrà su un altro piano,
allora continueremo a vedere
donne di qualsiasi età
che si rifiutano di abbassare la testa,
di chiedere scusa, di essere relegate
a un ruolo di mera utilità.
E che piuttosto di essere confinate,
se ne andranno da questo mondo
facendo un grande, vertiginoso salto.
(Applauso)
Da quando è arrivata,
mia figlia mi ha insegnato
che la vita è un cammino,
che facciamo mano nella mano,
lungo la grande strada della storia,
che tracciamo insieme.
E...
i libri delle date
sono scritti dagli uomini,
e questa è una grande notizia.
Perché abbiamo ancora da scrivere
la storia delle donne.
Se oggi sono femminista,
se riconosco, sostengo e supporto le
rivendicazioni delle donne del mio tempo,
è perché ho con me i fantasmi
di tutte le donne della storia.
L'esercito delle pessime mogli
che hanno combattuto per essere persone.
Chi sono queste donne?
Dobbiamo sforzarci di ricordarci di loro,
di che persone erano,
e non solo a che cosa sono servite.
Il primo maggio del 1947
il corpo di Evelyn McHale
è precipitato su una Limousine.
Quell'auto apparteneva a
un uomo che stava scrivendo
insieme a molti uomini e poche donne,
quella che l'anno successivo
sarebbe diventata
la Dichiarazione universale
dei diritti dell'uomo.
70 anni fa.
Ci sono voluti 65 anni
perché le Nazioni Unite
rendessero operativo un ente
che si occupasse di realizzare pienamente
l'articolo 1 di quella dichiarazione,
per il primo soggetto di violenza,
discriminazione e repressione:
le donne di tutto il mondo.
Siamo alla fine di una storia
e siamo nel mezzo
di una nuova grande storia.
Quale sarà questa storia
dipende da tutti noi, insieme.
È il momento di ricordarci
che esiste un'altra storia,
più complessa, quotidiana
e collettiva insieme.
È quella fatta anche da molte,
moltissime donne.
È il momento di ricucire
i frammenti delle loro vite,
come persone e come
protagoniste degli eventi.
È il momento di riaverle qui,
con noi, perché siano:
le ombre benevole, le radici vive
di tutte le rivendicazioni che ancora oggi
le donne chiedono
in tutte le parti del mondo,
perché oggi più che mai:
women's rights are human rights!
Grazie a tutti!
(Applauso)